[Music]
it would seem that the fairest blessings
have been granted to the most distant
nations of the world whereas in helis
the seasons have by much the kind least
temperature as I've lately said India
lies at the world's most distant eastern
limit and in India all living creatures
four-footed and flying are by much
bigger than those of other lands except
the horses which are smaller than the
median horses called 'no sayin
moreover the gold their weather dug from
the earth or brought down by rivers or
God as I have shown is very abundant
there too grows on wild trees or wool
more beautiful than excellent than the
wool of sheep
these trees supply the Indians with
clothing again Arabia is the most
distant to the south of all inhabited
countries and this is the only country
which yields frankincense and myrrh and
cassia and cinnamon and gum mastic all
these but ma are difficult for the
Arabians to get they gather frankincense
by burning that store acts which
Phoenicians carry to Hellas this they
burn and so get the frankincense for the
spice sparing trees are guarded by small
winged snakes of varied color many round
each tree these are the snakes that
attack Egypt nothing save the smoke of
storax will drive them away from the
trees the Arabians also say that the
whole country would be full of these
snakes were it not with them as I have
heard that it is with a Vipers it would
seem that the wisdom of divine
providence as is but reasonable has made
all creatures prolific that are cowardly
and fit to eat that they be not minish
from off the earth by devouring we're us
but few young are born to creatures
cruel and baneful the hare is
so prolific for that it is the prey of
every beast of bird and man alone of all
creatures it conceives in pregnancy some
of the unborn young are hairy some still
naked while some are still forming in
the womb others are already being chased
and killed but whereas this is so with
the hare the lioness are very strong and
bold beasts bears offspring but once in
her life and then but one cub for the
uterus comes out with the cub in the act
of birth this is the reason of it when
the cub first begins to stir in the
mother its claws much sharper than those
of any other creature tear the uterus
and as it grows much more does it
scratch and tear so that when the hour
of birth is near seldom is any of the
uterus left hole
it is so - with Vipers and the winged
serpents of Arabia were they born in the
natural manner of serpents no life were
possible for men but as it is when they
pair and the male is in the very act of
generation the female seizes him by the
neck no let's go huh grip - she have
devoured him thus the male dies but the
female is punished for his death
the young avenge their father and eat
their mother while they are yet within
her nor were they dropped from her till
they have devoured her womb other snakes
that do no harm to men lay eggs and
hatch out a vast number of young the
Arabian winglet serpents do indeed seem
to be many but it is because whereas
there are Vipers in every land these are
all in Arabia and are nowhere else found
the Arabians get their frankincense as I
have shown for the winning of cassia
when they weak it it binds oxides and
other skins over all their bodies and
faces leaving only the eyes cassia grows
in a shallow lake round this and in it
are encamped certain winged creatures
very like bats that squeak shrilly and
make her stout resistance these must be
kept from the men's eyes if the cassia
is to be plucked as for cinnamon they
gather it in a fashion even stranger
where it grows and what kind of land
nurtures it they cannot say say that it
is reported reasonably enough to grow in
the places where Dionysus was reared
there are great birds it is said that
take these sticks which the Phoenicians
have taught us to cool a cinnamon and
carry them off to nests built of mud on
the mountain crags where no man can
approach the Arabian device for
defeating the birds is to cut into very
large pieces dead oxen and asses and
other beasts of burden then to set these
near the iris withdrawing themselves far
off the birds then fly down it is said
and carry the morsels of the beasts up
their nests which not being able to bear
the weight break and fall down the
mountainside and then the Arabians come
up and gather what they seek thus is
cinnamon said to be gathered and so to
come to Arabia from other lands but gum
mastic which Greeks call leaden on and
Arabians laden on is yet more strangely
produced its scent is most sweet yet
nothing smells more evilly than that
which produces it for it is found in the
beards of he-goats
forming in them like tree gone this is
used in the making of many perfumes
there is nothing that the Arabians so
often burn for fragrance I have said
enough of the spices of Arabia as
wondrous sweet blow from that land these
then are the most distant parts of the
world in Asia and Libya but where south
inclines westward the part of the world
stretching farthest toward the sunset is
Ethiopia here is great plenty of gold
and abundance of elephants and all
woodland trees and ebony and the people
are tallest and fairest and longest
lived of all men these then are the most
distant parts of the world in Asia and
Libya but concerning the farthest
western parts of Europe I cannot speak
with exactness for I do not believe
there is a river called by foreigners
air Adonis issuing into the northern sea
when Sir Amba is said to come nor have I
any knowledge of tin islands whence art
in is brought the very name of the air
Adonis Perez itself is not a foreign but
a Greek name invented by some poet and
all for all my diligence have I been
able to learn from one who has seen it
that there is a sea beyond Europe this
only we know that our tin and amber come
from the most
distant parts this is also plane that to
the north of Europe there is by far more
gold than elsewhere in this matter again
I cannot with certainty say how the gold
is got some will have it that one eyed
men called arimaspi ins steal it from
Griffin's but this too I hold incredible
that there can be men in all else like
other men yet having but one I suffice
it that it is but reasonable that the
most distant parts of the world as they
enclose and wholly surround all other
lands should have those things which we
deem best and rarest
[Music]
you
[Music]